i don't know i was just like not like
surprised because i'd like done karaoke
with you
the most cheesy situation possible
with homelanders when a narcissist uh
tries to
parent it is uh bumpy at best
that doesn't mean sacrifices won't still
be made
erin we need to talk about the first
episode because seeing starlight at
translucent's funeral
and that gorgeous voice was just so
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
what was that like for you and was that
really you singing is that your real
life superpower
no it is me saying
my introduction into the world of like
performing and doing anything was seeing
but that was when i was much younger
and that was what i initially wanted to
do i wanted to be a singer and then
it turned into acting so it was cool i
mean when chris when eric kirk
your shoulder approached me he was like
listen
you're gonna see a power ballad in
episode one of season two
and we're gonna go for it we want it to
be as celine dion-esque as possible
we're gonna lean into the cheese factor
i was like
i am in i was nervous i would say
singing gives me stage right more than
anything else but luckily like i got to
record it before
and then on the day it was more like lip
syncing it was such a perfect like when
i read that and i found out that that
was the first
moment you were gonna see me in season
one that just the most cheesy situation
possible with homelander and that like
thing going on in the background with
photographs of the translucent i just
was gung-ho about it well and also her
hair is is so much bigger this season
but i think it's because it's full of
secrets
yeah i mean that truly could be said
if that's and if that's the case then
her hair is just gonna
get to the point of being bigger than
her body i was on set one day and eric
was there and he was just like come here
and he just pressed play on his phone
and he basically showed me the track the
pre-recorded track
you sing so well and i don't know i was
just like not like surprised because
i've like done karaoke with you
but it was just like it's so good i was
so impressed
yeah i know it's gonna be a bop it's
gonna be the end of summer jam
it was really fun it was really fun
especially because like it's not meant
to be taken seriously
so i could just go for it i liked it
yeah me too it's really great
one of my favorite things that they've
done with homelanders character is given
him his son
because in the graphic novels butcher
actually killed the baby
so anthony what has that been like for
you to really get to see homelander try
to embrace his
his father's side his twisted father's
side emphasis on the word
try that's the great thing about this
show and this is what
eric said right off the bat when we came
into season two he said whatever the
characters think they've got and
whatever they're holding on to and
whatever they've been fighting for and
achieved in season one is going to be
taken away across the board not just
the homeland but all of the characters
and and he was true to that
forces the characters and then so in
turn the actors to think on behalf of
the characters in
a different way and to adapt and evolve
and grow and
it keeps everything fresh you know it
really keeps you on your toes the
parenting thing i mean
yeah what do you say i mean when a
narcissist
tries to parent it is uh bumpy at best
and we've seen the first bump which is
the kid's head on the lawn and then uh
it kind of goes
uh neither uphill or downhill just goes
and sort of swings and roundabouts from
there so
it's very interesting from episode three
on them
wow that's a good that's impressive
from just a writer's perspective just
being practical
the kid is a perfect character he's half
the thing
butcher loves most in the world and half
the thing butcher hates most in the
world you don't get rid of that
character you just you use that
character
because they're just too perfect not to
from the very very beginning of the show
we knew we were gonna keep that
child alive and have becca be raising
him
because there's just so much to talk
about and he has indeed in season two he
has just a huge impact on all the
characters and
he draws out weird paternal instincts
and
homelander who is spoiler alert a
truly father it gives billy butcher like
a whole new
motivation in the season it did so many
great things that that for us we just
you know we wanted to understand that
i love the fact that no character seems
to be off limits when it comes to death
in this show is that how you view it are
you looking to just really be like no
one is safe
yeah i mean i think that's a really
healthy tension for the audience
um to never quite understand or never
quite know who's going to live and who's
going to die
you know you have to do it every so
often because
you start to fall into a pattern of like
oh well i know
this character is safe and so i'm not
going to engage as much in a dangerous
situation but
it's the real world we're trying to show
these are superheroes in the real world
and
in the real world you know people die
all right hands in the air
like you just don't care kill well your
show is so
wonderfully messed up from the gruesome
things that you get to get away with to
the things that come out of your
character's mouths is there anything
that amazon was ever like oh eric
maybe we'll just pull that back a bit
you know uh in season two definitely not
they would have been amazing because i
think they started they they knew me by
now
by then in season one uh almost never
they were
awesome about it they did for some
reason they were okay with launching a
dolphin through a windshield
they objected to that the dolphin wanted
deep to masturbate him
right seriously now is not the
appropriate time for some reason that
was their
line of like we're uncomfortable that
the dolphin is asking the deep for a sex
act
and my response was i'm like dolphins
actually are the horniest creatures in
the world and so
we're just being honest and i started
sending them all these articles which if
you search online is true that they're
like
they're perverts so i just had to be
accurate to science
it's science it's science science there
was one
queen with homelander that they made me
cut in season one
um but without giving the spoiler away
like with season two i found uh
maybe that season maybe that scene will
come to light again maybe i found a
sneaky way to get it back in that is
amazing
and you my friend are a true hero
you